ashley is with us in Pittsboro are in
Indianapolis hi actually how are you I'm
good thanks so much for taking my call
sure what's up okay so my husband and I
have recently started your program we're
in baby step one right now and he I stay
at home with our son but he makes about
65 a year and then we have about 63 a
little over 63 in debt and fifteen
thousand of that is vehicles both of our
vehicles so I was wondering should we
sell one of them we would be upside down
about 7,000 or should we just keep it
and keep parking on how are you upside
down on one of them 7,000 when the total
debt is only 15 on - well I guess what
I'm saying is it appraises it's a truck
the first one is a truck what do you
want we are about thirteen seven on it
so the other car hadn't hardly got any
dead on at all and thirteen seven and
you think it's only worth six actually I
think it's on a good day would be about
seven Wow no I don't think cars are your
issue it's not it's not that big a part
of the problem plus if you sold it you
don't get rid of that much now two sixty
three thousand you get rid of five
thousand bucks you know cuz you're still
gotta have something drive so no it
doesn't that's not that's not good it
doesn't move the needle enough to fix
the problem
and so what is the rest of the debt
other than the fifteen year old the two
cars we have 33 in student loans and
then two thousand as private cards or
three thousand was a personal personal
loan and then five thousand medical and
ten thousand is a settlement okay I said
your stay-at-home mom how many kids I
just once okay how old right okay good
okay so what I want him to do is look
for extra work and I want you to think
of some things you can do to generate
income from home and I want you to
become an expert home economist your job
is to squeeze every dollar with coupons
and consignment sale clothes and
anything else we can do to squeeze every
dollar out of this house you're not
going out to eat again for three years
you're not going on a vacation for the
next three years because that's what
it's going to take you guys to get this
debt cleared beans and rice rice and
beans
because right now you're stuck you're
down in a well you're stuck lassie is
Timmy in the well yeah you're in the
well that's where you are you're stuck
right and so you got to do something
pretty dramatic to break out of this
dramatic mess that you're in the level
of drama that you have to implode into
your life insert into your life is is
you know in relation to the level of
drama you're in just think about this
what if you had no payments oh my gosh
your life would be completely different
so what is it worth what kind of price
would you pay to get there well beans
and rice rice and beans for two and a
half to three years extra work by both
of you anything you can do to create
some extra income and knock this debt
out as fast as hard as you can using the
debt snowball it's exactly what you need
to do this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]